hello internet my name is Dave Rubin I
am the newest host here on The Young
Turks Network we're doing a show called
the Rubin report my last name's Reuben
it just kind of worked out perfectly it
was me or Ruben Studdard I work cheaper
so here we go I am very excited to be
doing a show with the Young Turks we're
gonna be doing a comedy panel talk show
kind of like the view meets SportsCenter
we're gonna be bringing in comedians and
personalities and social media people
and people I meet on the street that
might have something interesting to say
we're gonna talk politics we're gonna
talk media we're talking basically
everything we're gonna do the whole damn
thing and we are not going to do pundits
and talking heads if you want to find
out what the administration thinks about
something turn on MSNBC you want to find
out what the Republicans think turn on
Fox you want to find out what two
Talking Heads who are just going to go
to lunch in the afternoon together turn
on CNN we're not going to do any of that
we're gonna find interesting topics and
we're gonna get to the heart of them and
and it's gonna be quick and painless
because you have things to do this is
the Internet you probably have porn open
right now I know what you're doing
so we're gonna be doing this once a week
clips are gonna come out every couple of
days I think you guys are gonna dig it
there is a subscribe button up here or
maybe up here it might be here I think
they're moving things around on YouTube
it could be over here or down here the
point is it's there somewhere you just
click it and then you will get the
episodes really simple and if you want
anything from me whatever you want you
want more funny you want less funny you
want different guests you want to be
against yourself go in the comments
leave me a little note we're gonna read
them see what's what and that is it so
subscribe and laughs and okay now back
to your porn